did Reddit just solve this season's
killer on True Detective and is there
someone at HBO who has purposely leaked
this information a word of warning as of
the writing of this video I have not
seen the upcoming episode so everything
here is purely speculative and could
easily be disproven next episode but I
did find this quite compelling so I had
to share with you and offer my own
insights if you do like this video be
sure to check out my full episode
breakdowns where we become detectives
ourselves trying to figure out what's
really going on in n now this Theory
comes to us from Reddit user for Rusty
brain and a quick look at their profile
reveals something rather interesting it
looks as though this is a burner account
created specifically for this post as it
was created January 29th 2024 the same
day this theory was posted other than
one response to the theory the account
has been silent also the username might
be a not to season 1's rust Cole whoever
this person is I get the feeling they
want to remain Anonymous the theory goes
like this and hear me out because at
first it seems a little bit far-fetched
but when you start piecing together the
clues it starts to make more sense
Navaro has a dormant Alter Ego or split
personality in episode 4 we see her go
into these trans-like states a state Liz
observes also happened the day they
confronted William wheeler stop it stop
it right you're doing the thing that you
did with wheeler this would imply that
it was Navaro who killed wheeler perhaps
as her Alter Ego took over and Liz
helped cover it up to make it look like
a murder suicide I want you to take a
look at these images the left is from
episode three in which Liz recounts the
wheeler story to Peter one which is
likely a lie because she says wheeler
was dead when they got there but he
clearly wasn't the image on the right is
from episode four in which Liz is
concerned that Navaro is seeing some
sort of ghost or spe while at Wheeler if
I were to guess who shot and killed
wheeler I'm going to go with the one who
is seeing visions then again there is
the possibility wheeler lunges at Navaro
noticing that she's in this trance and
Liz shoots him in defense but my money
is currently on Navaro Navaro goes on to
call these voices she hears the family
curse something that happened to both
her sister and mother while at the
dredges we can even hear a female voice
calling out Navarro's
name and this isn't just any voice but
that of the Inuit goddess sedna a
mythical being that was hinted at in
episode one this picture that Darwin
Drew shows what Kao refers to as a local
Legend of a woman whose fingers have
been cut off in the myth of sedna sedna
has her fingers cut off by her father as
she clings to a canoe before falling
into the ocean where she becomes ruler
of the underworld in Navarro's first
scene we see her helping a woman who has
her fingers cut off now I went and
searched the actress who plays the
fingerless woman and she has all of her
fingers so the decision to have some of
her fingers removed was a very conscious
one by the creators pulling off the
fingerless effect requires hours of
Prosthetics or green screen and just
adds another layer of complexity to the
shot so there must have been a reason to
go through the trouble of including it
when asked about who she prays to dvaro
says she doesn't pray to anyone rather
she listens something a God would do now
cyna is known to be the ruler of the
underworld and Navaro just so happens to
be haunted by the dead these include her
mother William Wheeler's girlfriend and
and Anders Lund all of whom point at her
in the same creepy manner Lund even
passes on a message that her mother is
waiting for her likely in Hell according
to Navaro her mother was murdered but
the murderer was never found was Navaro
the one to kill her that being the first
time this Alter Ego manifested the myth
goes on to explain that sedna was
mistreated by her parents and orphaned
we don't know much about Navarro's
father and Navaro had to take care of
her little sister after the death of her
mother an alter ego would also explain
how her mother's necklace somehow got in
the car the night she almost drove into
a truck how did it get there sedna is
also known to control animals in episode
one we saw these Caribou leap over the
edge and the owner of the Crab Company
states that their usual crab spots are
turning up empty sedna lives under the
sea and what kind of toothbrush does she
love SpongeBob who lives in a pineapple
under the sea we know Navaro has this
thing about protecting women Navaro is
obsessed with the case she's got this
thing about women who get hurt
especially protecting women from abusive
men this lines up with the snth whose
father cut off her fingers after she
refused to marry any of the men found
for her and instead marries a dog
Navarro's best friend is Eddie cavic
whose first name means good friend in
Old English and last name means wolf in
Inuit so you could make the argument
that Eddie is Navarro's good wolf friend
in her hallucinations novaro also sees
Holden's pajamas covered in dogs
speaking speaking of wolves the first
time we see Rose she's skinning a wolf
sidna is worshipped by hunters Navaro
doesn't know her aupc name her mother
never told her but maybe her alter ego
knows and it will be revealed that it's
sna or one of several other names this
goddess has gone by over the centuries
sedna is known to be a vengeful goddess
Navaro is quick to violence we see this
in episode 1 and her wrath against the
men in episode 4 but how did this Alter
Ego manifest it may have something to do
do with the trauma Navaro endured
growing up with a mentally ill mother or
even what she experienced when she was a
soldier this aspect of her life is
something she never talks about and
we've only seen bits and pieces of it
when Navaro sees a soldier with half her
head blown off it could be a metaphor
for Navaro only being in control of half
her mind the other half belonging to
this Alter Ego it can be inferred that
her Alter Ego then becomes a defense
mechanism to protect her from the pain
and Trauma of the outside world I also
want to talk about these spirals found
in Raymond Clark's notes they're
accompanied with the words eyes but what
if they're not supposed to be eyes at
all take a look at this image here looks
a lot like those spirals but it's
actually the orbit of a small body on
the edge of our solar system called you
guessed it sedna which at the time of
its Discovery in 2003 was the furthest
known object away from our son in the
True Detective podcast Jody Foster even
says that this season is all about
Navarro's journey and that Liz is only
there to support it she was the
character that was supporting kayle's
character Navarro's childhood also
mimics an old innuit folk tale called
The Boy From the Bottom of the Sea who
frightened the people of the house to
death it tells the story of a mother who
ran away from an abusive husband and
built a house at the bottom of the sea
where she gave birth to a child this
child would grow up and scare the
villagers frightening them to death and
I can't help but think of those salal
scientists who looked absolutely
petrified when their bodies were found
both lond and raymon Clark talk about a
woman having been woken up which may be
a nod to Navarro's Alter Ego waking up
in an interview with Vanity Fair
showrunner Issa Lopez is quoted as
saying that unlike season 1 where the
Killer is rarely seen until the second
last episode the character or characters
that quote committed the deed are right
there in front of you through the entire
series now there's also a world where
Navaro is sedna but not the killer why
would she kill all these scientists I
mean I could see her wanting to kill
Raymond if she believed he was Annie's
murderer I think a truly shocking reveal
would be if it was Navaro who killed
Annie but she didn't know it it was her
Alter Ego that did it remember that
Navaro somehow knew it was Annie's
tongue found at salal and Darwin's
picture of sidna shows her eyes crossed
with what looked like stars Annie's body
was said to have starshaped wounds shout
out to the binget toown TV podcast who
theorize these wounds may have been
caused by ice cleats which would explain
the 32 stamps one kick would create
multiple incisions and we do know that
an k was kicked after she died friend
showed that someone kicked her after
they dumped her dead Bist as of episode
4 there's only been one character shown
wearing these cleats and that's Eddie
cavic while out ice fishing but look to
the left here and we'll see Navarro's
black boots this is interesting because
in the season 1 teaser trailer you'll
see a person with black boots wearing
these cleat but to be fair lots of
people in Alaska have black boots and
cleats we also see Peter on the ice with
cleat but he has brown boots cleats can
also be found in Oliver T gak's cabin
but he has different boots as well
regardless this is yet another tiny clue
that Navaro may have been involved in
Annie's killing while this Theory
doesn't explain everything it's one of
the more compelling ones I've seen out
there but what do you think is Navaro
experiencing some sort of dissociative
disorder or is this theory about as
believable as an orange in the tundra I
want to hear your thoughts in the
comments below thanks for watching be
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes follow me on Twitter and
Instagram at@ thinkstory YT until next
time remember Daddy loves you very
much